i got a little excited about getting you
guys uh
letting your hands get dirty on this and
i bless you forgot to answer the last
part of part a
so let's just quickly look at that it
says hence find what
in part a maximum maximum speed right so
we're returning back to this idea of
speed rather than velocity now we have a
velocity equation and that will be our
way of finding out
speed now i already i rubbed off what
our derivative was before because we
didn't even know
what a lot of it we didn't know what a
was at that point we didn't know what
alpha was
do we need to know what alpha is by the
way for maximum speed
we actually don't that just affects
where it is that this is happening but
the maximum speed is still going to
happen at the extremes of motion okay
sorry not where
when is when it affects but from here i
can just differentiate right i had i
think from memory
minus 6a which in this case is minus 30
sine and then for completeness i will
write the rest of this
but can you see why actually the rest of
this does not matter
i actually have enough information as
soon as i write down this
what is the not the domain what's the
range of
sine anything what's the range
it's from negative one to one right
that's the maximum you can get out of
this part of the equation so therefore
if it goes from negative one to one
then really this is the decisive part
this is the part that tells you
magnitude okay
i'm not worried about that negative
because i'm just asking being asked for
speed
so therefore i can just say what's my
unit of speed in this quest
it's centimeters per second so i can say
30 centimeters per second
that's my maximum speed i can just read
that off
the amplitude question the speed of the
velocity function
the amplitude of the velocity function
is
30 the negative turns me upside down but
that doesn't affect how far i can go
i think to find way to think about it
the only danger i would say
change is another right word the caution
i would give is when i think of
amplitude i think about how far i'm
moving
right and this is not about how far i'm
moving it's about how fast i'm going and
the same thing for an acceleration
equation if i cared about that
but just objectively this is a trig
function that's the amplitude
of the trig function as long as you
remember what this particular trig
function is telling you
which is velocity okay good question
let's tie this up we're really at the
tail end there's not much to do here
but it's there's still enough traps here
to fall into that i want us to do it
together
if you have not written something like
this like this first line here if you've
jumped straight to here
please go back and write something um
you've got so many equations flying
around and so many points at which
you're like i'm doing this now
i've changed my direction of logic right
tell me what on earth you're doing not
just for my sake
but also for yours so you can go back
and when you're checking your solution
you're like what was i doing here like
an hour ago in the exam can't remember
all the trig equations look the same
describe to me clearly communicate
once you've done that i i'm literally
just sort of substituting in this is my
displacement equation right
there's my x i'm setting it equal to
three because i'm trying to return back
and i've just sort of rearranged a teeny
tiny bit okay now at this point here
i could say well i just want to get rid
of cos
right so i could do inverse cos cos
inverse of both
sides before i write that down though oh
hold on a second yeah that's right
oh that's right no i know i know i know
i know why i've had a problem that's
okay
um when i get to this point right i've
got
cos inverse of three-fifths on this side
but that's actually only one of the
solutions
right it's only the first quadrant
solution that identified
there's an infinite number of 60 plus
alphas that satisfy this
equation so when i write down alpha
cos inverse of three-fifths that's just
the first time
that it happens and this is actually not
the one i'm really interested in
can you see if this was the equation
that i wrote down it's kind of a trivial
solution isn't it because you'd subtract
alpha from both sides
you get six t equals zero well we knew
that because that's the initial
condition
make sense i need the next one the next
time that it happens
think about this this is cosine right
it's moving up down and then
up right the next time this happens is
it not 2 pi
minus alpha here's a first quadrant
solution and here's a
fourth quadrant solution as it were okay
now just for the sake of completeness
even though i don't need it for this
particular question
maybe they'll next time ask us for like
what happens after that when will the
next solution be
yeah it's going to be my first quadrant
solution plus a whole
period right which in this case should
be 2 pi plus and so on
right first quadrant solution fourth
quadrant solution the first quadrant
solution
again and then so on okay which is the
one that i want it's going to be
this one here this is actually the one
that's relevant to answering this
question right
so i'm going to say next uh
time at x equals three this is my
justification
for choosing one of the solutions and
ignoring the rest right you know it's a
pet paper
i was to sort of say yeah i'm just going
to choose i've got multiple solutions
and i'm just going to take one of them
because i want to no give me a reason
does that make sense justify
what i got 6 t plus alpha equals 2
pi minus alpha and i'm solving for t
here right so i've got this it looks
like 2 pi
minus 2 alpha yes by the way any
suggestions why i've gone back to
writing alphas rather than my value over
here
it's an approximation because that's an
approximation and also i am lazy that's
like five digits i you know i know what
i'm talking about i've set a value for
alpha over there
um t equals pi on three minus alpha
on three just dividing through by six
can you give me a
zero point seven four because i think
they asked for two decimal
places happy times okay now
as promised i need to go and unfreeze
this screen
excuse me i want to show you what
happens if
you decided at the beginning to choose a
sine nt plus alpha rather than cos i
gave you a compelling reason
i hope to choose cos and it gave us this
particular value
of alpha which was acute cool but you
didn't have to right and you can still
solve it but i just want to show you why
maybe you want to try and avoid that
hopefully you can see what's going on
here i've i'm following along my working
from before i have this center of motion
that was unspecified so i specified it
right
that gave us our let me just get this
for you
that gave us our velocity and
displacement equations here but a lot of
it was unknown
the same stuff i didn't know before a
and t and alpha
the time was unspecified so i specified
it there's my t equals zero and then off
i go
this should look very familiar by the
way because it's just an analog of what
we did before
i get the same amplitude think about
this why do i get the same amplitude
simon goes yeah the same function just
moved left right so that doesn't change
what's going on up down
right so same value of a but then when i
go to the next part
when i go to solve for alpha something
different happens have a look right
i go to sine alpha equals three-fifths
for starters i had
cos alpha equals three fifths before so
you're like oh that's objectively
different
that's because i've switched things
around my displacement and velocity
equation are different
but this is the more important part and
this is actually the thing i'm seeking
to avoid it's why i chose cos in the
first place
if you have a look back at my equation
one and two for this
because when i differentiated whoops up
here see how there's no minus sign up
there
because sine doesn't differentiate to
negative cos it differentiates to
positive cos right so when i come down
to here i divided through by negative 4
so then sorry negative 6.
so then this negative appears over here
sorry i didn't divide through by
negative 6. that's why the negative is
still there from my original
v equals negative 24. so now i've got
this equation here
sine is positive and this equation here
causes negative
right so you're not in the first
quadrant anymore right are you following
with me
so therefore here i say ah i have to be
obtuse
because my options are different so i've
got this angle here
i know we're not so used to reading an
angle in radians and thinking is that
acute is that obtuse that's why i
referenced before
the tip over is pi on 2 1.57
so this is me going pi minus this in my
calculator to get the obtuse angle the
calculator will just hand you the acute
one okay
so then here's what i've got i've got a
whole different equation compare that to
this
here it is right here's the original one
i had and this is the new one
that i've got if you'd like you can go
into desmos and you can see these are in
fact exactly the same equation because
sine and cos are off by
pi on two so that's the difference there
do you recognize do you see 2.498
how off is it from 0.9273 answer
pi on 2 right 1.57 etc
and then when you go through right
because i've now got different equations
when you go through to solve
it looks a teeny bit different right um
here's me doing the same thing
displacement equation equals three
i divide through by five now here you
just have to be quite
careful with what's going on right just
compare this line
to this line see this i had a first
quadrant solution and a fourth quadrant
solution
and then here's my first quadrant
solution again but further along
excuse me here i don't have a first
quadrant and a fourth quadrant solution
i'm solving for sine so i get a first
quadrant and a second quadrant solution
look its sine is positive so quadrant
one
sorry quadrant one quadrant two right
and then you get the next one over and
the next one
you said to be careful with this one
though because since alpha is obtuse
pi minus this is actually not going to
give me the solution that i want so i
have to ignore that one
go to the second one and then go to i
want the next time it comes to x equals
three
which is this guy do you see why this is
confusing when you get an obtuse angle
it's like ah
gross i like which angle do i have to
choose if you get something nice and
acute and this is why jae was mentioning
this before
you want alpha to be acute if you
possibly can okay
so therefore choose choose a function
that will make it so you don't have to
shift
so far you don't have to introduce such
a large phase but of course
as you'd expect you still get the same
solution if of course you do it right
uh which i didn't the first two times i
did this because i got confused by my
obtuse angle even when i knew it was
obtuse
so i try to avoid that if you can ciao
for my initial phase i had a negative
value
instead of like an obtuse angle so i had
a negative of acute angle
and then for that way the high minus
alpha just works out
yep so if you wanted to go from uh here
you can see
when i went from one and two right i
said okay this
is positive this is negative so i drew
alpha being obtuse from there but that
was because of me just internally going
i'm solving from naught to two pi not to
two pi so therefore those are my only
options and then i have my a
and negative five yeah yeah yeah so uh
you've got sorry are you saying here
you've actually got negative five
sine of and then you've got an acute
angle over here but negative
yeah angle first and then to make that
to fit into that angle it has been
negative yeah okay i
i'm going to caution you from doing that
because you start to think about um
flipping your function upside down and
introducing a different shift
it's just another extra place to confuse
yourself you'll get it right i mean
there's no reason why if i introduce a
negative five here
uh it's still the same sinusoidal wave
it's just a different
shift right um but you can see like this
is our like
nice neat version it's it's positive
it's acute it's easier to solve does
that make sense so i'm really just
highlighting this other form of working
to show you